[Music]
fire and blood will rain again and you
can expect to see the blackfire
rebellions in the later seasons of house
of the dragon
that includes one of the most prominent
and key figures from this time period
bryden bloodraven rivers who was the
main targaryen general fighting against
blackfyres
the same man who would later go on to
become the three-eyed raven and teach
bran stark
his abilities the upcoming game of
thrones prequel sirius house of the
dragon is based on the george rr
martin's targaryen history book fire and
blood
house of the dragon is a game of thrones
prequel show that is confirmed by hbo's
president to air in 2022
miguel sapochnick and ryan condell will
serve as showrunners and
executive producers george r martin will
also serve as executive producer
it's based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book firing blood
volume 1
and on martin's yet unfinished firing
blood volume 2 book
fire and blood begins their tale with
the legendary aegon the conqueror
creator of the armed throne and goes on
to recount the generations of targaryens
who fought to hold that iconic seat
all the way up to the civil war that
nearly tore their dynasty apart
in other words it covers events from
aegon's conquest to the dance of the
dragons
that's fire and blood vol 1 house of the
dragon will start with a build up
towards the dance of the dragons
in early seasons we'll cover the dance
itself later seasons however will be
based on george r martin's yet
unfinished fire and blood vol 2 book
the atana released fire and blood vol 2
will continue from where part 1 ended
with rhaenyra targaryen's son aegon the
third's reign
and will cover blackfyre rebellions the
war with dorne and go all the way to the
mad king
and robert's rebellion attended
targaryen dynasty
as i already said one of the most
important characters from this time
period of the blackfyre rebellions was
sir brindon rivers
called lord bloodraven he was the
bastard son of king aegon iv targaryen
by his sixth mistress lady melissa
blackwood
he had two older sisters and numerous
half siblings
as his mother was highborn brinden was
counted among the great bastards
like his bastard siblings brian was
legitimized by king aegon iv
in 184 ac bryden's personal
arms were a white dragon with red eyes
breathing red flame on a black field
bryden was an albino and thus had milky
white skin
long white hair and red eyes on the
right side of his face he had a red wine
stain birthmark
that extended from his throat up to his
right cheek from which he earned his
name bloodraven
as the birthmark was said to look
somewhat like a raven drawn in blood
brinedan was not as tall or muscular as
his half-brothers
daemon blackfyre and egg were
bittersteel but he was considered more
cunning
brined and carried the valyrian steel
long sword dark sister
and was a good swordsman he was an
expert bowman who preferred to use his
tall weirwood longbow
bryden was rumored to be a sinister
sorcerer and spymaster who effectively
ruled the kingdom
with spies and spells and as lord
bloodraven
a popular riddle asked was how many eyes
does lord bloodraven have
a thousand eyes and one the song a
thousand eyes and one was written about
bryden
bryden was resented by his half-brother
igor rivers
nicknamed bittersteel at some point
bryden became a lover to his half-sister
shira sea star as aegor desired her as
well
shiera became another point of rivalry
between the two half siblings
bitter still became a great champion in
general for his half-brother daemon
blackfyre
while bloodraven became a great champion
in general for his half-brother deyron
ii targaryen
the first blackfyre rebellion ended in
196 ac
with the battle of redgrass field in
which daemon blackfyre and his
eldest two sons were slain it was
bloodraven's private company of archers
known as the raven's teeth who rained
arrows down
upon daemon blackfyre and his two eldest
sons
killing them many called bloodraven a
kingslayer for this
although no one knew exactly whose
arrows had killed daemon
he was pierced by many the arabs are
said to have been driven by bride and
sorcery
daemon's death led the rebels to route
but some were rallied by ego rivers in
mad
charge the resulting duel between the
rival half brothers left brined and
blinded in one eye
and they go retreating the battle was
lost
but bitter still managed to escape and
became one of the major leaders of the
surviving blackfire forces
as they fled into exile in the free
cities daemon left behind five sons
and multiple daughters so bitter still
became their guardian
they would continue to harass the seven
kingdoms with plots and failed
rebellions for decades
after king daron ii died in the great
spring sickness of 209
ac he was succeeded by his son aerys the
first targaryen
who proved to be weak absentee king
more concerned with introverted
scholarly pursuits than
any form of governing veneris the first
was crowned however
bloodraven was named as the new hand of
the king a position he held
throughout aerys is the first 12 year
reign
during that time bloodraven was the real
power behind the tron
and the functional ruler of the seven
kingdoms aerys
is the first rule was deeply troubled by
plague drought and
insurrection and many blamed blood raven
because he was in charge
but ultimately he was the man holding
the realm back from the brink of chaos
during this troubled period
during his time as hand of the king
bryden was not only an effective
administrator and strategist
but a cunning spymaster and the
information from his secret agents
greatly aided his grip on power
his spies were so widespread that also
referring to the eye he lost in battle
a popular riddle at the time asked how
many eyes does lord bloodraven have
to which the answer was a thousand eyes
and one
some people alleged that bryden and his
paramore his half-sister sierra seastar
used sorcery to uncover secrets during
the wedding journey at white walls
in 212 ac and through his informants
including a man at arms and a troop of
comic dwarves
bryden was aware of a plot at white
walls to put damon the second blackfyre
forward
as the legitimate lord of the seven
kingdoms brined and marched on the
tourney with 300 raven's teeth
three brothers of the kingsguard 500
daughter knights
and 5 000 infantry drawn from the
crownlands and the riverlands
in the face of sacha forts daemon tried
to rally the tourney goers to battle
but found little support daemon then
challenged blood raven to single combat
grinding refused and arrested the
pretender thus containing the second
blackfyre rebellion
daemon was kept in captivity rather than
executed
with the other rebel leaders ensuring
that the igor rivers could not name his
brother hagon as a serious pretender
however daemon died few years later
while a hostage in the red keep
and hagon and bitter still launched the
third blackfyre rebellion
the third blackfyre rebellion featured
the second duel between brinden
and his half-brother bittersteel at the
end of the final battle the pretender
hagon was dishonorably killed
after he had surrendered and had given
up his sword
bitter still was taken captive in the
aftermath of the third blackfyre
rebellion
brinden argued that the captiva river
should be put to death
but king aerys the first targaryen
decided to send aegor to the night's
watch instead
however ago rivers escaped back to essos
when his ship was intercepted and route
to eastwatch
thus the blackfyre plotting continued
brindin continued as the hand for aerys
successor
his brother maegor the first in 221ac
after menger's death in 233 ac brinedan
as the hand of the king
called the great council in king's
landing to discuss disputed matter of
succession
aerys the first died in 221 ac without
issue so he was succeeded by his younger
brother maegor targaryen
even though maegor distrusted his uncle
he kept bloodraven as hand of the king
maegor ruled for 12 years and was then
succeeded by his own son
aegon v targaryen also known as
egg during the great council that put
aegon the fifth on the throne
amy's blackfyre had sent word from the
free cities
that he wanted to put himself forth as a
legitimate candidate
blood raven promised him safe passage
and dane is accepted in good faith
but as soon as he set foot in king's
landing the gold cloak seized him
and dragged him to the red keep where
blood raven promptly executed him
this was decried as utterly dishonorable
but blood raven said he willingly paid
the price to remove one more potential
blackfyre pretender
and accepted exile to the night's watch
as punishment
in 233 ac the year he was crowned
aegon v had bloodraven sent north as
part of the honor guard
that escorted his older brother maester
aemon to the wall
bryden took dark's sister with him and
he went to the wall
in time blood raven rose to become the
new lord commander
he served long and well in this position
but one day he went out alone
ranging beyond the wall and mysteriously
never returned
around 50 years later branstark
discovers that brinedan is still alive
as a three-eyed crow the last green seer
living with children
of the forest in a cave beyond the wall
in george r.r martin's books the 3a
raven reveals the following
i wore many names when i was quick but
even i had a mother
and the name she gave me at her breast
was bryden he also tells bran this
i have my own ghost's bran a brother
that i loved
which would be theron a brother that i
hated which would be bittersteel
a woman i desired which would be sierra
the three-eyed raven also said to brand
the following
i have been watching you all of you all
of your lives with a thousand dies and
one
we know that the popular riddle asked
about bryden in his youth was how many
eyes does lord bloodraven have
a thousand dies in one the song a
thousand eyes and one was written about
bryden
so that's a nice little final
confirmation of lord bloodraven that he
indeed became the three-eyed raven
that's the story of the main targaryen
loyalists fighting against the
blackfyres in the blackfyre rebellions
brined in rivers known as lord
bloodraven legendary characters such as
bride and himself as well as daemon
blackfyre and bittersteel as well as
dozens of characters coming before them
in the dance of the dragons
legendary battles such as the battle of
redgrass field and many other coming
before and after
all of that and more this game of
thrones prequel show house of the dragon
brings in 2022
although the rebellions will be in the
later seasons of the show thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
video please give it a big thumbs up and
i hope to see you in the next one
peace